casablanca en mode commando
depuis quelques jours la fourgonnette de
l'association insaf est plein à craquer
et opère dans les rues de la ville pour
distribuer des aides alimentaires aux
mères célibataires déjà fragile cette
catégorie de population est plongé dans
la détresse par la paralysie économique
du pays
les quartiers populaires de cette région
sont sous tension entre le confinement
obligatoire le désoeuvrement et l'argent
manquant tout doit se faire très vite et
surtout à l'abri des regards pour éviter
de faire des envieux s'ajoutent à ça une
aube sociales liées à leur statut de
mère célibataire savez suite à cette
épidémie qui a touché le tout le tout le
monde tant qu'on a pensé à nos
bénéficiaires et qu'on a essayé de faire
en sorte que ces glissières le manque de
rien
donc depuis deux semaines on a essayé de
on est en train de chercher pour qu'on
puisse déjà préparé les denrées
alimentaires de base en touche de type
de famille en touche 3 me en clavet dans
le rural dans à ne pas oser appeler à
berlin et aussi on a des femmes des
familles
des maires chefs de famille
monoparentale qui vise à casablanca et
qui sont bénéficiaires de nos projets
l'association est chaque année plus de
500 jeunes femmes tombées enceintes hors
mariage reconnu comme un péché par la
société conservatrice ces femmes sont
victimes d'exclusion sociale
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses un
rapport publié par l'inps ça fait l'onu
recense air 2011 près de 30000
accouchement de mères seules chaque
année au maroc avec la pandémie tout a
changé
les premiers appels au secours ce sont
intensifiées environ 15 jours après la
mise en place de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
le 20 mars dernier des livraisons
d'urgence partent aussi dans des hameaux
isolés de la région où vivent des
familles précipité dans la misère à
cause des effets de la pandémie doublée
d'une grande sécheresse cette année
l'opération qu'on voit actuellement nous
sommes en train de préparer à 200
paniers qu'on va distribuer dans la
province de chichaoua et plus
particulièrement dans des réserves
clavé et cite une opération qui vient
ensuite à la prochaine opération qui a
ciblé les deux régions de chichaoua et
house et sur laquelle on a distribué 300
paniers aux familles nécessiteuses
la plupart de ces femmes vivent de
petits boulots dans la coiffure le
ménage l'industrie textile ou la
restauration et se retrouve privé de
ressources sans filet de sécurité
la vulnérabilité de ces mères
célibataires s'est accentuée avec la
crise sanitaire pour répondre à
l'urgence
l'association a dû appeler à la
rescousse les donateurs habituels et
collecter de nouveaux fonds